[Musik]
fußball kann so spannend sein dramatisch
und am Ende tragisch zumindest aus Sicht
der Fans von Borussia Dortmund einmal
geht ihr Team als Favorit in den letzten
Spieltag und dann wieder nichts wieder
platzt ein Traum
fußball kann so spannend sein dramatisch
und am Ende mit Happy End aus Sicht der
Bayern-Fans mit Ach und Krach hat ihre
Mannschaft in den letzten Spielminuten
geliefert und wieder mal heißt es Bayern
München ist Deutscher Meister
aber trotz des elften bayern-titels in
Folge Katja gibt es auch ein
Paukenschlag beim Personal das kann man
wohl sagen die Bayern trennen sich von
Oliver Kahn und Hassan salamitis dazu
gleich mehr es war jedenfalls heute so
mit der verrückteste letzte
Bundesligaspieltag seit sehr sehr langer
Zeit egal wie es personell bei den
Bayern weitergeht nach den beiden
abpfiffen in Köln und Dortmund waren die
Spieler einfach nur glücklich eine
verkorkste Saison endet dann doch
immerhin mit einem Titel und man sieht's
an den Gesichtern besonders knapp
errungen der Triumph fühlen sich wohl am
besten an dabei konnten die Spieler nur
mit einer Kopie der Meisterschale feiern
das Original war nämlich in Dortmund wir
gehen jetzt zu Florian schiedrich der
ist für uns in der bayerischen
Landeshauptstadt Florian wie ist die
Stimmung in München
[Musik]
ja wir sind hier an der Leopoldstraße wo
eigentlich in den letzten Jahren die
bayern-titel nur von einer Handvoll Fans
gefeiert wurde jetzt aber bildet sich
hier wirklich ein atemberaubender
Autokorso der auch tatsächlich immer
dichter und immer lauter wird denn
natürlich vor diesem Spieltag hat ja
kaum einer damit gerechnet dass es hier
heute noch etwas zu feiern gäbe aber mit
dem Rückstand der Dortmunder kam der
Glaube zurück und dann kurz vor Schluss
der auch noch die bayerische Führung und
nicht nur der Glaube sondern auch der
Fakt das ist was wird mit den 11
Meistertitel nacheinander und wie
emotional das ganze war das zeigt Ihnen
jetzt noch einmal Stefan Bier
[Applaus]
es ist das alte Lied von Münchner Fans
jetzt bei insgesamt 33 Meistertiteln
angestimmt nur mussten sie diesmal
ziemlich leiden
es Wahnsinn
man hat es nicht mehr geglaubt
zwischendurch ja gerade nach dieser
Saison
nicht sagen haben sie selbst noch damit
gerechnet gerechnet ja aber nicht dran
gedacht ehrlich gesagt aber ich freue
mich umso mehr jetzt als der Ausgleich
in Köln fällt ist der Meistertitel für
die Bayern zwischendurch mal wieder
futscht der Biertisch wird zur
Folterbank
ich war noch nie so wenig nervös wie
heute bis zur Halbzeit weil ich wusste
dass sie wieder genau wie die letzten
Spiele sondern 1:0 irgendwas passiert
und es geht in eine falsche Richtung
wohl dem der dann den Namen musiala auf
dem Hemd stehen hat der Name des
siegtorschützen der die Bayern ein
weiteres Jahr Meister sein lässt
sonst war es nie so spannend bis zum
Ende und jetzt
in Dortmund angeboten und das macht es
noch richtig süß in die Suppe gespuckt
zu haben es ist immer noch München das
heißt es wird nicht das Gleiche
passieren hier auf dem Borsigplatz aber
es ist auch okay ist mir scheißegal ein
bisschen Auto gab es dann aber doch
schon der Tag ist ja noch lang
so wir bleiben bei Florian schiederich
in München Florian Bayern trennt sich
nach
Informationen von Vorstandschef Khan und
Sportvorstand Salami was ist da los in
München
[Applaus]
ja also mittlerweile sind diese
Informationen tatsächlich auch bestätigt
das ist ein absoluter Paukenschlag
eigentlich sollte es die
Aufsichtsratssitzung ja erst am Dienstag
geben aber nun ist die Entscheidung
schon vorhergefallen und das erklärt
auch warum Oliver Kahn der
Vorstandsvorsitzende gar nicht im
Stadion in Köln gewesen ist es hieß erst
der habe Grippe gehabt mittlerweile hat
sich Oliver Kahn hier Zwitter gemeldet
dass sie mit der Weg ins Stadion und der
Besuch in Köln untersagt gewesen ist
dieser Tweet ist mittlerweile aus ZDF
Infos zu Informationen auch bestätigt
hat also seine Richtigkeit also ein
absoluter Paukenschlag aber irgendwo
natürlich auch die Frage jetzt hier in
München was das für ein Stil ist das so
zu kommunizieren Thomas Tuchel
jedenfalls selbst ist geschockt nach
dieser Entscheidung das hat er gesagt er
wurde gestern schon informiert Florian
vielen Dank für diese tapfere alte Grüße
nach München und wir gehen jetzt gleich
dorthin wo eigentlich alles
angerichtet war für eine gigantische
Meisterfeier nämlich nach Dortmund zu
Heiko Rams Heiko wie schwer sind die Fan
Herzen dort gebrochen
die ferienhetzen hier sind wirklich sehr
schwer gebrochen die Trauer ist hier
unermesslich ich habe Fans gesehen die
geweint haben Männer die sich in den Arm
genommen haben Frauen natürlich auch und
die sich gegenseitig versucht haben zu
trösten um das was sie gerade erlebt
haben irgendwie gemeinsam zu verarbeiten
im Stadion waren 80.000 Fans hinter mir
ging gerade die letzten nach Hause in
der Stadt waren es noch viele viele
tausend mehr dich war verteilten über
zahlreiche Kneipen und alle gemeinsam
sind jetzt hier in Trauer und versuchen
zu verarbeiten was sie gerade gesehen
haben Dortmund trauert
vielen Dank Heiko nach Dortmund
jetzt seinen harter Schnitt viele
Deutsche womöglich hunderte werden
Russland wohl bald verlassen müssen
darunter Diplomaten Lehrer und
Kulturvermittler hintergrund ist eine
neue Obergrenze die Russland anfangen
juni einführen will neben
Botschaftspersonal geht es um
Mitarbeitende in Kultureinrichtungen wie
der deutschen Schule in Moskau oder den
Goethe-Instituten wir fragen nach bei
fülliger in Moskau Filme viele Deutsche
werden Russland verlassen müssen was
steckt denn dahinter
ja das ganze geht zurück auf die letzte
Runde an Ausweisungen im April hatte
Berlin ungefähr 30 russische
Botschaftsmitarbeiter nach Hause
geschickt unter anderem weil die
nachrichtendienstlich tätig gewesen sein
sollten daraufhin hat Moskau dann auch
ungefähr 30 deutsche Diplomaten
ausgewiesen und eben damals schon
angekündigt eine Deckelung einführen zu
wollen für alle die an deutschen
staatlichen Institutionen hier tätig
sind da ist jetzt von etwa ungefähr 350
Menschen die Rede und diese Obergrenze
die deckelt eben nicht nur deutsche und
auch nicht nur Diplomaten denn am
Goethe-Institut an der Deutschen Schule
und auch an der Botschafter arbeiten
auch russische ortskräfte und viele von
denen werden jetzt ihren Job verlieren
vor allem sind diese neuen Restriktionen
aber ein weiterer Einschnitt natürlich
ins bilaterale Verhältnis denn jetzt
müssen deutsche Kindergärten oder
Sprachinstitute ihr Angebot reduzieren
also ausgerechnet die Orte an den
Deutschen und Russen bisher noch
einigermaßen unproblematisch miteinander
ins Gespräch gekommen sind
live aus Moskau war das für Bedarf
vielen Dank für die Information
es bleibt spannend in der Türkei dort
ist morgen die Stichwahl für das
Präsidentenamt 61 Millionen Wähler sind
zur Stimmabgabe aufgerufen sie wissen
vor zwei Wochen holte Präsident Erdogan
49,5%. sein Herausforderer Rollo der
bekam
44,9%. der 74-Jährige Kilic Stader Rollo
von der Mitte Linkspartei CHP hat es
geschafft 6 Parteien ganz
unterschiedlicher Lager
zusammenzubringen als Favorit geht
allerdings Erdogan 69 seit Jahren Kopf
der islamisch konservativen AKP einer
Feist berichtet
ob er morgen noch einmal wählen wird das
weiß-jiancara noch nicht er ist Kurde
und enttäuscht von der Regierung sowieso
und nun auch von dem Oppositionsbündnis
um chemotklitsch derulou ja nicht schöne
die einen sind leizistische Faschisten
die anderen sind konservative Faschisten
sofern es um uns Kurden geht der Krebs
der sich Nationalismus nennt hat sich in
Ihrer Haut gefressen seine Wut sie kam
vergangene Woche da hat auf Stimmen
fangen Erdogans Herausforderer eine
Allianz geschlossen mit der
ultra-nationalistischen sufferpartei und
so tanzt die Opposition nun mit
rechtsextremen wolfsgruß
2% der stimmen könnte das neue Bündnis
der Opposition bringen doch wie viele
kurdische Wähler dafür verprellt werden
bleibt abzuwarten sein Gegner Präsident
Erdogan Fax zumindest schon einmal
gestern in Istanbul auf wahlkampf-tour
hinter verschlossenen Türen verhandeln
Sie mit allen sie haben 40
Parlamentssitze an drei oder vier
Parteien vergeben
[Musik]
am Montag wird es bei denen ein
Schlachtfeld geben
in gewohnter Manier schießt Erdogan
gegen den Kontrahenten bezichtigt ihn
der Zusammenarbeit mit Terroristen der
unterdessen beklagt ungewöhnlich wütend
unfaire Wahlen und Lügen ich frage dich
Erdogan soll ich auf die Wahlen
verzichten es ist das was du willst so
kann man keine Wahlen abhalten so ein
Feigling
doch Aufgeben tun sie trotzdem nicht
noch fährt die Opposition weiter ihre
Strategie wird die Nationalflagge
verteilt auf den letzten Metern
jetzt der Blick nach Serbien
international gibt es dort große Sorgen
und die Aufforderung auch von westlichen
Staaten nach Zurückhaltung wegen der
Zusammenschlüsse gestern zwischen
nationalistischen Serben und der
kosovarischen Polizei Serbiens Präsident
Vucic hatte danach die Armee in erhöhter
Alarmbereitschaft versetzt aber nicht
nur deswegen heute Proteste in der
Hauptstadt Belgrad Britta Hilpert
berichtet
es ist die vierte Demo gegen Gewalt in
Belgrad trotz Regens werden wieder 10
tausende erwartet denn zum Entsetzen
über die Amokläufe kommt immer mehr Wut
über die Regierung und ihre Medien dazu
es ist mehr als ein Protest gegen Gewalt
es richtet sich gegen die falschen Werte
dieses Regimes
die Gesellschaft muss sich ändern sie
kann das erst wenn auch die Regierung
sich ändert die es seit 12 Jahren gibt
auslöser waren zwei Amokläufe in zwei
Tagen Anfang Mai mit insgesamt 18 Toten
die Täter nutzten legale und illegale
Waffen Präsident kündigt deshalb
schärfere Waffengesetze an in Serbien
gibt es bis zu 3 Millionen
illegale Waffen Regierungs nahe Medien
zeigen Massen an Waffen doch tatsächlich
wurden bisher nur ein bis zwei Prozent
abgegeben die Balkan Krieger heilen nach
und Spannungen mit den Nachbarn
wie auch gestern Serben und Albaner
geraten in benachbarten Kosovo
aneinander
versetzt deshalb seine Armee in höchster
Alarmbereitschaft und eskaliert Barbara
bei der ersten Attacke auf Serben im
Kosovo wird Serbien nicht tatenlos
zuschauen
negativ Costa de Kroko der krisenmodus
soll für ihn mobilisieren so auch
gestern bei der Demo die die Regierung
organisierte es ist aber auch diese
Politik gegen die sie heute auf die
Straße gehen
Rücktritt rufen Sie es reicht also nicht
das wusstet sich nun vom Parteivorsitz
zurückzieht die Demonstranten verlangen
mehr es wird nicht die letzte Demo gegen
Gewalt und Regierung sei
zurück nach Deutschland der
antisemitismusbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung klein warnt vor
Judenhass an Schulen und fordert eine
Meldepflicht für entsprechende Vorfälle
wir stellen fest dass Antisemitismus
auch an Schulen verbreitet wird er gehe
nicht nur von Schülern sondern auch von
den Lehrkräften aus sagte Klein den
Zeitungen der Funke Mediengruppe
außerdem werde in manchen Schulbüchern
jüdisches Leben beschrieben wie vor 2000
Jahren
das geplante heizungsgesetz sorgt bei
uns für Frust und Zoff da lohnt sich der
Blick ins benachbarte Ausland in
Dänemark zum Beispiel wird die
wärmewende offenbar viel unkomplizierter
gemanagt dort setzt man nicht auf
Wärmepumpen für einzelne Häuser sondern
auf das fernwärmeprinzip große
dezentrale Anlagen versorgen viele
Haushalte Sword Cali zeigt es uns
der Hafen von Esbjerg wenn dieser
schwarzen Halle entsteht die Zukunft der
Energieversorgung für die dänische
Küstenstadt hier bauen Techniker eine
der weltgrößten Wärmepumpen sie zieht
Wärme aus dem Meer und speist sie in das
Heizungssystem ein
Drittel der Haushalte in Dänemark sind
an das Fernwärmenetz angeschlossen das
heißt die können alle auf einmal durch
die Wärmepumpe von Kohle auf erneuerbare
Wärme umgestellt werden ohne einen
Heizung
bisher sorgte ein Kohlekraftwerk für
warme Wohnungen das soll nun
abgeschaltet werden 60.000 Tonnen CO2
spart die dänische Stadt jährlich durch
ihre neue Pumpe gebaut hat sie das
deutsche Unternehmen M a n
in Deutschland haben wir auch Anfragen
aber ich sage mal wenn ich den Vergleich
mache mit den nördlichen Ländern ob das
Norwegen ist ob das Dänemark ist sind
wir durch die Bank hinweg mit diesen
neuen Technologien einfach hinterher
bereits seit 2013 sind in Dänemark Öl
und Gasheizungen in Neubauten Tabu den
deutschen Streit um die Wärmepumpe
versteht man hier nicht
Wärmepumpen liefern preiswerte Wärme da
sie mit grünem Strom betrieben werden
und der ist in Dänemark günstig da wir
viel windkraft und Solarenergie haben
ab Oktober stellen sie in esberg um von
Kohle auf grüne Fernwärme aus der
Wärmepumpe
bei einer Demonstration von
klimaaktivisten in den Haar hat die
niederländische Polizei mehrere hundert
Menschen festgenommen die Aktivisten
hatten zum 7 mal eine Autobahn in der
Nähe des Parlaments blockiert damit
wollten sie laut eigenen Angaben gegen
die Energiepolitik der Regierung
protestieren
jetzt zu Pfingsten da nutzen viele die
freien Tage für einen Kurzurlaub das
verspricht natürlich frischen Umsatz in
Hotels und Restaurants gut für eine
Branche die seit Jahren schwer zu
kämpfen hat denn die corona-pandemie
ließ die Geschäfte ja gewaltig
einbrechen es geht jetzt nur langsam
bergauf das alte Niveau ist noch nicht
wieder erreicht ein Grund ist die
Inflation und vor allem klagt das
Gastgewerbe über den Fachkräftemangel
Susanne Seidel berichtet
auch wenn es zum Baden noch zu kalt ist
viele Kurzurlauber sind über die
pfingstage ins Ostseebad Boltenhagen
gekommen Giuseppe golia kann sein
Eiscafé trotzdem nicht öffnen es fehlt
ihm an Personal die Lage ist sehr sehr
schlecht man kriegt keine Leute rein
keiner möchte arbeiten gabs paar
Bewerbung aber die meisten schauen sich
das an und sag mir zu anstrengend
während der corona-schließungen haben
viele Angestellte die Branche verlassen
neue Mitarbeiter kamen kaum nach ein
Trend der auch nach Ende der Pandemie
anhält in den vergangenen drei Jahren
verlor die Branche deutschlandweit rund
67.000 Fach und Hilfskräfte
Unternehmen wie dieses vier-Sterne-Hotel
in Boltenhagen locken neues Personal
inzwischen mit Prämien und kostenlosem
wohnen andere bieten eine vier Tage
Woche das Grundproblem bleibt das Thema
demografischer Wandel trifft natürlich
am aller härtesten die Bereiche die
besonders personalintensiv sind und da
gehören wir dazu aber auch Einzelhandel
und andere und von der Sache haben wir
kein branchenproblem sondern wir haben
insgesamt ein Problem im Restaurant zum
Klabautermann geht ohne die polnischen
Angestellten gar nichts mehr
ich habe ein super polnischen jungen
Koch gekriegt eine Servicekraft noch
sind wir auch total glücklich drüber
aber auch ihre Fachkräfte aus Polen sind
heiß umworben weiß Cornelia Dunkelmann
sie hofft dass sie sie in ihrem
Restaurant halten kann
die Reiseziele erstmal zu erreichen gar
nicht so einfach wenn alle zu Pfingsten
unterwegs sind deshalb kam es heute auch
zu Staus besonders in den südlichen
Bundesländern so viel Verkehr und ein
Unfall auf der A8 bei Gruibingen in
Baden-Württemberg hieß das bereits heute
früh stundenlanger Stau und zeitweise
Vollsperrung der Autobahn ab dem
Nachmittag entspannte sich die Lage dann
und alle konnten weiterfahren
so jetzt noch mal zur Fußball-Bundesliga
und den Emotionen und den Eindrücken aus
Dortmund genau so sieht's aus der BVB
macht aus einem 0:2 Rückstand noch ein
zwei zu zwei aber dieses Unentschieden
reicht am Ende eben nicht totale Stille
im Stadion neben und auf dem Platz
laufen trennen enttäuschung pur nach
einer so knapp verspielten Meisterschaft
lange Gesichter in Dortmund die
Meisterschale war zum Greifen nah doch
am Ende bleibt die pure Enttäuschung
wir sind alle im Boden zerstörte wir
sind alle traurig alle richtig traurig
traurig ich glaube dass das richtige
Wort und das Schmerz extrem einfach nur
nach Hause ist schade
es war ein Wechselbad der Gefühle 80.000
Fans im Stadion Tausende in Dortmund
Kneipen oder bei privaten Partys die
Zuversicht am Anfang riesig der Titel so
gut wie sicher doch dann beginnt der
Krimi mal ist Bayern vorne dann wieder
Dortmund bis zur letzten Sekunde ist
alles möglich am Ende fehlt den Borussen
das entscheidende Tor der Traum von der
Meisterschaft ist geplatzt
ja und hier nun alle Ergebnisse des
letzten das 34 Spieltag Dortmund Mainz
2:2 Köln Bayern 1:2 Leipzig Schalke 4:2
Stuttgart Hoffenheim eins zu eins Bochum
Leverkusen 3:0 Union Berlin gegen Bremen
1:0 Frankfurt Freiburg 2:1 Wolfsburg
Hertha 1:2 und Gladbach Augsburg
2:0 schauen wir auf die Tabelle die
Bayern sind wie schon gehört zum 11 mal
nacheinander Deutscher Meister dank der
besseren Tor Differenz Dortmund Leipzig
und Jahr erstmals auch Union Berlin
spielen kommende Saison in der Champions
League Freiburg in der Europa und
Leverkusen in der Conference League bei
der zweiten Hälfte blicken wir direkt in
den Keller und sehen das Stuttgart in
die Relegation muss gegen den Hamburger
SV nächste Saison in der zweiten Liga
spielen Schalke und die Hertha
ja er hat da stand schon länger als
absteigerfest Schalke nun also auch nach
sieben Siegen zehn Unentschieden und 17
Niederlagen in der Saison die
Schalke-Fans haben bis zuletzt gehofft
und gebangt dann aber doch die
Gewissheit zum fünften Mal in der
Vereinsgeschichte müssen die Blau-Weißen
in die zweite Liga
hat nicht geschafft hat aber ich bin
zufrieden dass du wenigstens nur drei
zwei verloren haben einfach nur traurig
hätte ja klappen können er hat zwar
keine große Hoffnung aber so ein kleines
bisschen Hoffnung hat man doch bis zum
Schluss immer noch
wir kommen wieder kein Problem wir
kommen wieder
na dann alle wichtigen Szenen dieses
spannenden letzten Spieltags können Sie
ab Mitternacht noch mal anschauen unter
heute.de und in der heute App und
natürlich schon vorher von 23 Uhr an wie
immer im Aktuellen Sportstudio zu Gast
ist ZDF Fußballexperte Sandro Wagner und
es gab tatsächlich noch anderen Sport
das einzige Flaggschiff des Deutschen
Ruderverbandes der Achter der Männer hat
bei der EM in Bled Slowenien eine
Medaille deutlich verpasst das neue
formierte Team Umschlag man mag kann man
hatte von Beginn an Problemen mit den
Top 3 Nationen mitzuhalten im Ziel
wurden sie knapp 6 Sekunden hinter
Großbritannien Rumänien und die
Niederlanden vierte da kommen Sie gleich
ins Ziel so jetzt aber dann danke ich
dir Katja mehr als 20 Grad Sonne dazu
natürlich keine Wolken und trotzdem ist
es in Leipzig gerade er düster denn da
läuft das Wave Gotik Treffen zum 30 Mal
kommen in der Stadt Anhänger
alternativer Subkultur en zusammen jung
und etwas älter völlig ausgeflippt und
etwas eleganter ja ja sprich alle die es
beflügelt auch optisch dem Alltag zu
entfliehen schwarze sehen mit Spaß wobei
schwarz nicht immer zutrifft auch hier
kommt es auf die kontraster
ja mit schwarzer Kleidung können es in
der Sonne ziemlich warm werden die
scheint nämlich weiterhin viel mehr dazu
gleich von Katja Horne fahren ihnen
seien noch das heute journal mit meiner
Kollegin Dunja Hayali ans Herz gelegt
22:45 Uhr geht's los wir sehen uns
morgen wieder schönen Abend und schönes
Pfingstwochenende
[Musik]
guten Abend so viel Sonnenschein über
Europa sehen wir wirklich selten da ist
gut zu erkennen wie noch Schnee liegt in
den Alpen auch die dicken Regen und
Gewitterwolken über Spanien sind zu
erkennen und wie neue Wolken von
Nordwesten herankommen bei uns in
Deutschland gab es heute aber nur ganz
wenige kleine Quellwolken und so ist die
Nacht klar und die Temperaturen sinken
auf 11 Grad in Frankfurt und bis vier
Grad in Erfurt und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperatur und dann zum meist bei
20 bis 27 Grad nur an den Küsten von
Nord und Ostsee bleibt es etwas kühler
und das liegt am Wind das ist nämlich
ein auslandiger Wind der kommt von der
See und die Nordsee hat direkt in
Küstennähe nur so 12 bis 14 die Ostsee
12 bis 16 Grad da sind einfach keine
höheren Temperaturen zu erwarten obwohl
morgen ganz verbreitet und meist vom
wolkenlosen Himmel die Sonne scheint
vielleicht sehen sie am Alpenrand mal
eine quellwolke und im Norden einige
hohe Schleier und sie gibt es eine sehr
hohe Waldbrandgefahr vor allen Dingen
hier im Norden und nordwestlich von
Berlin hohe Waldbrandgefahr gibt es aber
auch in Franken und im Oberrheingraben
in den nächsten Tagen geht es genauso
weiter bis auf eins an den Küsten wird
es etwas wärmer schöne Pfingsten